[موسيقى]
اختراعاته مهدت لثوره في الصناعه
الكهربائيه حول العالم المخترع والعالم
الفيزيائي الايطالي اليساندر فولتا
ولد في مدينه كومو الواقعه في شمال
ايطاليا في العام
وتلقى تعليمه في مدارس المدينه
قام بتدريس الفيزياء بالمدرسه الملكيه في
كومو وشغل كرسيه رئاسه الفيزياء التجريبيه
في جامعه بافيا لما يقرب من اربعين عاما
لفولتا العديد من الاختراعات الا ان
عمادها كان اختراع البطاريه الكهربائيه
وذلك في العام 1799
اختراعه هدم النظريه السائده انذاك بان
الطاقه الكهربائيه لا يمكن توليدها الا
عبر الكائنات الحيه واثبت انه يمكن
توليدها كيميائيا
فسر الاليه التي تعمل بها الكهرباء بعد
اكتشاف التيار الكهربائي صدفه من قبل
الفيزيائي الايطالي لويجي جلفاني وقد احدث
ذلك ثوره في الصناعه الكهربائيه حول
العالم
اهتم فولتا بدراسه الجهد الكهربائي واطلق
على وحده قياس هذا الجهد فولتا والتي ما
زالت مستخدمه حتى يومنا هذا
كما درس فولتا الغازات الكيميائيه واكتشف
غاز الميثان
نال فولتا اعجاب الامبراطور الفرنسي
نابليون بونابرت وادعي الى معهد فرنسا
لاثبات وعرض اختراعاته امام اعضاء المعهد
كما منحه نابليون العديد من الاوسمه
رغم الحضور الكبير لفولتا في المجتمع
انذاك وقربه من نابليون بونابرت الا انه
عاش شبه منعزل خاصه في اواخر ايامه مفضلا
البقاء مع افراد اسرته
توفي في العام
1827 بعد اصابته بالعديد من الامراض
[موسيقى]